salut c'est monsieur gros ça fait à peu
près un mois que je t'ai cette fameuse
monde connecté déjà parlé dans une
première vidéo dans lequel j'ai réalisé
un homme boxing d'ailleurs j'invite
aller voir cette vidéo est maintenant je
vous donnais mon sentiment par rapport à
cette mode connecté
un mois après l'avoir essayé et on y va
maintenant
c'est une chaleur d'or c'est à peu près
quelque chose comme 31 degrés dehors
chaleur épouvantable tant mieux on est
enfin au mois de juillet on est
aujourd'hui le 1er juillet c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle casquette
oblige pour se protéger il fait
extrêmement beau c'est une super
nouvelle donc très très belle journée
pour vous parler justement de cette
fameuse monde connecté il ya plein de
points positifs il ya aussi des points
négatifs donc bon je vais essayer de
vous guider si toutefois cette monde
vous intéresse pour vous dire au final
est ce qu elle vaut le coup est ce qu'il
faut rester à qui elle s'adresse à qui
et ne s'adresse pas quelles sont ses
limites tout de suite je commençais par
le point négatif comme ça c'est quelque
chose de rédhibitoire pour vous ce sera
clair net précis c'est une montre qui
n'est pas du tout traduite en français
par ci voulait absolument une monde
connecté en français ce ne sera pas
cette fille qu'il faudrait acheter doré
ce moment là alors passez votre chemin
si ça vous dérange pas de l'avoir soit
en anglais soit chinois soit au russe
pourquoi pas on peut aussi se tenter
comme ça à ce moment là cette monte là
peut être pour vous et peut vous
intéresser alors ce que je trouve moi
par contre de très intéressant et ce qui
m'a vraiment mais vraiment surprise dans
cette montre c'est son autonomie elle
est complètement hallucinant jamais le
matin en me levant je l'enlève le soir
quand je me couche et c'est à dire
quelque chose vers 7h 7h30 du matin je
m'équipe je l'avais j'enlève le soir et
à l'éliminer heures du mat up j'enlève
la montre pendant une semaine elle ne
bronche pas c'est à dire que je vais
l'utiliser sept jours sans avoir de
faiblesse au niveau de l'autonomie sont
devant la recharger ça c'est juste
exceptionnel avec non apple watch à la
recharge est à peu près tous les deux
jours il n'y a pas non plus le même
écran on va pas avoir la même luminosité
par rapport à une apple watch par contre
en terme de longévité
c'est vrai que ça m'impressionne un
point sur lequel j'étais aussi un petit
peu mitigé dès le départ c'est le côté
un peu de carbone un peu épais alors moi
j'ai pas des poignets qui sont énormes
par contre regardez up
cela prend je l'enlève vous allez voir
tout de suite parce que c'est vrai que
du point de vue design elle est pas
moche elle est pas non plus sublime
vous avez vraiment effet carbone là donc
si vous craignez ce côté carbone c'est
pas forcément fait pour vous c'est assez
épais c'est assez masculin bon ça peut
aussi conduire une femme dès lors qu'on
aime les objets forcément un peu plus
masculin
voilà après c'est pas une bombe vilaine
esthétiquement elle est quand même radio
offre pour sa part une notification
après c'est pas mal une jolie montre
mais c'est vrai que malgré tout c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est assez
épais et ça on peut pas lui enlever
après le bras s'attache très très
facilement c'est un système qui est
extrêmement classique
ça marche bien voilà donc après j'ai
absolument rien à reprocher à cette
montre un elfe est bien la faire elle
marche bien je vous dis l'autonomie est
complètement hallucinante
là ça fait je sais pas combien de jours
que je les recharger et je suis à peine
à 58%
donc franchement voilà ça en terme
d'autonomie grand point positif là
dessus parce que je vous dis avec mon
apple watch j'en suis très très très
très très loin
alors au début il ya un truc qui m'avait
un petit peu fait bizarre c'est le
système pour le brancher lorsque vous
voulez le recharger c'est à dire que au
début je trouvais pas ça extrêmement
évident je vais vous montrer
au début je trouvais bizarre c'était la
connectique il suffit juste de les
mettre en face l'un de l'autre
sauf que une fois que je les pose et je
les branches et bien évidemment la
recharge se faisait pas laisser une nuit
j'ai pas compris il a fallu ensuite que
je me rends bien compte qu'il suffisait
pas de les mettre en face il faut
vraiment bien venir le clip c'est ici
qu'ils viennent vraiment bien se loger
voilà il faut qu'il soit vraiment bien
logés vraiment bien calés d'un côté et
de l'autre pour qu'ensuite on puisse se
faire et lorsque vous le branchez là on
voit la charge à paraître
et là ça marche sinon ça marche
relativement bien d'ailleurs vous
remarqué lorsqu'il faut l'enlever il
faut tirer dessus pour que ça sorte
après la montre en elle même je trouve
vraiment bien réussi plutôt bien fait
hop vous appuyez salariés active vous
avez votre petit mode de navigation vous
allez vider sur la droite sur la gauche
vous avez quelques infos ici vos infos
du jour vos activités
votre sport on devrait y faire rentrer
tout à l'heure votre écran d'accueil
votre rythme cardiaque
votre musique votre alarme
la météo du jour voyez aujourd'hui c'est
quand même relativement go 1 32 degrés
on crame ici est la boussole le
chronomètre votre sommeil
votre training center yes et ensuite on
a un timer voilà on a fait un petit tour
un peu complet de tout repos pour
trouver alors ce qui est vraiment
intéressant pour moi est ce qu'ils aient
marqué qui est la chose la plus
intéressante c'est vraiment côté sport
où vous allez avoir plein plein plein
plein plein plein plein d'infos vous
êtes bien évidemment la course la marche
à pied le cyclisme la natation la course
d'intérieur le cyclisme d'intérieur fin
de la machine pour charge de la montée
vous pouvez faire du trial run away
notes et un triathlon donc à pas mal de
choses c'est vraiment une solution
globale
pour votre entraînement quotidien et ça
je dois reconnaître que c'est quand même
super bien alors au delà des différentes
activités en retrait sur l'écran
d'accueil vous allez hop vous montez dit
si vous avez ici vos notifications du
jour instagram youtube tout ce que vous
voulez qu'ils sont directement la la
c'est une petite mise à jour à faire
twitter alors vous pouvez effectivement
les supplier vous pouvez les mettre en
silencieuse et hop une fois que vous
venez là que vous défendez de ce côté là
vous avez le mode nuit le mode avion
peut régler votre luminosité vous avez
ça qui est beau de luminosité là les
pousser à fond pour qu'il faudra mais la
poussée à fond pour que vraiment on en
profite pour une bonne belle luminosité
est ici vous avez vos réglages dans les
réglages vous avez vos réglages d'une
connexion en wifi en bluetooth
vous avez ici les infos de la montrant
pieds traditionnel le format du leurre
les ut toutes les informations sur le
mode avion il est pas mal de deux
petites choses c'est quand même
relativement bien fait je veux
reconnaître que sur le coup c'est bien
fait bien bien fichu implose update
device les infos sur votre montre reboot
pauvres en bref à tous à vos
applications ici vous pouvez gérer
directement depuis cet endroit là et les
petites infos au niveau de la montre là
le web minable mais pas mal de choses
donc c'est quand même une manche je
trouve qui est bien faite qui est bien
pensé ici vous pouvez utiliser les
boutons pour avancer et pour reculer
comme vous le serez avec vouloir silva
vous endetter si vous avez les médecins
à vous avez les bisons qui marche très
bien le bouton ici pour venir valider
pour allumer une nouvelle alarme a fait
un petit bac
ici un petit retour ça vous ramène sur
l'écran principal vous pouvez aussi
piloter votre montre depuis votre
smartphone vous allez pouvoir avoir
différentes informations vous pourrez
changer ici votre écran d'accueil de
votre montré pas mal de différentes
possibilités alors ghana qui sont plus
ou moins bien réussi à certains trucs
qui sont quand même un petit peu un
petit peu venu de l'espace
il faut le reconnaître il ya des trucs
je suis pas un grand fan des trucs qui
sont quand même un peu particulier mais
des choses qui sont assez bien réussi et
d'autres beaucoup moins
ça prend coup c'est quand même
relativement bizarre vous avez ce mode
là
qui est pas mal pas mal de petites
choses ça vous le choisir et vous verrez
c'est assez assez bien réussi je trouve
perso j'ai choisi ce qu'ils appellent
i'm valeur parce que vous avez les infos
ici sur votre batterie vous avez ici et
les infos sur notre nombre de pas
d'activités sportives
voilà ce que c'est assez complet c'est
assez moderne et pour vous c'est pas
moche
ensuite dans votre application vous
pouvez voir pas mal de choses vous avez
si votre activité vous avez ici votre
montre vous voyez combien ce qu'il vous
reste deux batteries pourrait
sélectionner ici votre écran d'accueil
de votre montre votre horloge un peu
classique la gestion de vos applications
sur ce que vous voulez mettre comme
réglages pareil pour l'activité sport
vous avez hop vous avez tous vos
réglages liés aux différentes activités
hivernales et ses plans pour la course à
pied
vous pouvez choisir ce que vous voulez
afficher ce que vous voulez voir les
calories la vitesse l'altitude
enfin c'est assez complexe trop pour
coup je dois reconnaître que c'est
vraiment un bon boulot qui est fait vous
avez ici la gestion de toutes vos
applications internes à votre montre que
vous voulez activer ou désactiver
vous pouvez aussi mettre à jour votre
système si vous le souhaitez vous avez
toute la partie sport qui se trouve là
avec un petit condensé de vos
informations par jour est signée ça
votre profil très complet avec votre
poids votre taille up toutes les infos
persos ici vous peut retrouver les infos
ressent dans votre vo2max les infos sur
votre montre si tous les paramètres
enfin je trouve que c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est quand même
extrêmement bien complet et il pouvait
régler si les unités je trouve que voilà
c'est une montre qui est quand même
globalement on va pas se mentir très
bien réussi c'est évidemment une monde
qui complètement résistante à l'eau nous
indique sur la boîte
quelques infos là dessus walter
résistantes aux quais jusqu'à 50 mètres
voilà on aux profondes plutôt pas mal a
priori en tout cas sur le papier je les
mises sous l'eau je suis pas allée nager
sous l'eau j'ai pris des douches ci n'a
pas craint normalement faut toujours
faire attention avec des montres comme
ça je ne sais pas c'est pas fait le test
mais néanmoins surtout faire attention
aux eaux salées et aux eaux chlorées
parce que pas que ça vaut l'endommagent
voilà donc moi j'ai été très choqué par
ces projets reçus cette boîte et qui est
vu marqué dessus
1 to five days bas
life je me suis dit ouais ouais d'accord
pourquoi pas c'est un petit peu un
argument commercial l'époque où c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment le cas c'est
très impressionnant parce que elle a une
vraie belle longévité et pour moi c'est
le vrai point positif de cette montre
pouvez calculer votre vo2max pour les
plus sportifs d'entre vous elle a aussi
une fonction gps enfin voila c'est
vraiment une montre un peu passe partout
qui va plus cette destinée je dirais à
des personnes qui vont utiliser pour une
activité sportive plutôt que des
personnes qui veulent une smartwatch
connecter avec une gestion des
applications un peu plus patravi main
peu plus passe partout comme une apple
watch
pour quelqu'un qui veut une montre un
peu sport celle là elle est vraiment
temps qu'elle va très très bien que je
vous dis une fois de plus c'est la durée
dit j'ai trouvé vraiment top
autre chose qui me semble un petit peu
au début en tout cas assez bizarre qui a
fait bizarre à par rapport à la pelle
watch c'est l'écran il ya effectivement
c'est payack l'écran on n'est pas
lumineux mais c'est vrai que j'ai
l'habitude d'avoir un écran extrêmement
lumineux par rapport à la pelouse ça ça
change un peu
c'est la qualité de l'écran qui
forcément un peu différente beaucoup
moins des couleurs ressortent beaucoup
moins il ya beaucoup moins de luminosité
c'est pas non plus du tout le même prix
on est une montre qui coûte quand même
moins 200 euros une apple watch avait
quand même beaucoup plus cher voilà la
différence on la ressent là dessus
forcément j'imagine que l'écran
consomment beaucoup moins que l'écran de
l'apple watch c'est aussi un peu ce qui
permet la longévité du produit voilà un
peu donc pour moi en tout cas cette
mouche dans la vie extrêmement positif
si toutefois le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
français c'est pas pour vous un point
rédhibitoire si elle vous intéresse vous
fait de l'oeil vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés et d'ailleurs si elle vous
intéresse vous a mis un lien en bas dans
la description
merci avant tout cas d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à blesser des
jolies poussent toutes vos questions et
interrogations directement en bas merci
à très bientôt soyez sages et d'ici là
vous embrasse simple
[Musique]